money and money and work are real issues
we all struggle with them and the reason
we all struggle with them is because
everybody is really struggling with them
our country is struggling with them
every business that struggles with them
but if you if you've worked in any
company in any corporation and you look
at their purpose statement or their
mission statement right their purpose
statement their mission statement is
full of great idealistic language it's
all about it's you know it's all about
the greater good
but what happens at the end of the
quarter the CFO comes in and says where
are the numbers and at that point the
great purpose statements go out the
window we struggle with the issue of
money and value and money and work
because it's just a common issue for all
of us but your question is really oh you
know it goes beyond that a little bit
which is since so many people are
struggling how do you sort of square
that and I think it's really difficult I
think everybody tries to find that
solution for themselves I think we try
to do the work that we like to do the
most in the way that we can and we hope
that at a certain point the work that we
really love will overtake the work that
we only like and sometimes you have good
choices and better choices and you move
to the better choice and sometimes you
have bad choices and worse choices and
then you can only take the bad choice
because it's better than the worst
choice so it's it's really an individual
solution but everybody has to find
there's no one common answer for that of
the creative individuals whom you know
whose sole source of income
from their creativity what are you doing
differently from those who are also
talented but earned only a fraction of
their income this way or possibly just
give away a lot of stuff for free what's
that determining factor that makes
someone able to monetize and passion or
the business of list or someone who just
does it and it gives away right well I
think there's three things the first is
one that's really unquantifiable that's
that's luck it's the luck of the draw
it's being at the right place at the
right time hitting the mark having the
talent that's really going to jive with
a market or an audience need at a
certain point a lot of that is kind of
outside of our control so let's talk
about the two things that are within our
control one is the people who really
monetize their talents do this thing
that a lot of artists are uncomfortable
with they say I'm worth something they
don't give it away I think that artists
are so used to giving things away for
free that artists devalue themselves and
devalue their work by doing that so I
think that artists kind of have to draw
a line you know there's a petition going
around now about the London Olympics
because the London Olympics committee
has asked the musicians to come and play
in London for free so what does that say
when musicians go ahead and do that
instead of saying no more artists we
have to put food on the table we have to
pay the rent so part of it is that I
think artists who really are able to
continually monetize their work just
draw the line do that uncomfortable
thing and say my work has value you have
to pay me for it they've gotten over the
difficulty of asking for money which I
know is difficult they've gotten over
the difficulty of selling which I prefer
to think of as offering but they do sell
they put the work out there you know you
can't really make money unless you offer
something for sale I know that that
sounds kind of you know like boneheaded
and obvious but it's really true and a
lot of the times that people are
creative you don't just stop and think
wow I have to offer something for sale
to give somebody the opportunity to give
me money so that's one this
second is that they are really outward
focused they really think about who's
the audience who's the constituency that
they are trying to reach and serve and
it really comes from a place of service
and they have the ability to be
hard-headed or hard minded in their
business perception and not make
decisions that are solely based on their
heart or their hope but based on really
looking at the marketplace looking at
the audience looking at their
constituents looking at the facts
looking at the numbers and say you know
what there's not really a big market for
this thing over here I might like to
paint paintings that are 12 feet by 14
feet but nobody can put it on their wall
and instead we have to make things that
people can put on their wall you know
one of my good friends is its
professional artist she shows in
galleries she makes a living being an
artist and she was recently telling me
that she's discovered that her clients
are more interested in quality over
quantity and she's really decided in her
next show which is up now she's doing
fewer paintings that are better she's
looked at the sizes people buy and she's
made them to that size so she knows how
they fit on the walls and she's really
customized her work to her constituents
to her audience to her collectors now
does that mean that she's compromised I
don't think so I think that she feels
really happy that she's able to share
her work and she's able to get into
other people's homes so they're able to
enjoy it
but it doesn't mean that she has
adjusted tweaked her work as it were for
her constituents
you